Hi, good morning, Wayne.
Good morning.
Anne Cohen.
Hey, Gagan, hello, Ben. Hope you're doing well.
Hello!
Are you keeping well when?
Well, of course.
Okay, that's great.
There's no other option.
Mmh.
Yeah.
Yeah, true.
Yeah, I always miss, I mean, your witty sense of humor. I mean, those were, I mean, those were the days I mean we used to, you know, connect on, you know, internal calls and your short one-liners, you know, would make everyone.
Well, we can have these meetings more often.
Ha.
Or he can go back working with you again.
Yeah.
I.
Oh, sure.
I am already working with them, but on a monthly basis, from the other side. Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
Ha.
It.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought you know Jim just jumped in. So when, are we expecting Jim to join in?
Jim won't be on today.
Okay.
All right, so let's get it started really quick and I'm sure you must be really busy. So in the interest of time, before we start off, Kevin or Wayne, anything that do you have before we start off?
I'm good.
No.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, so I'm sorry, one of the CX team members who needed to join this call, you know, he got multiple calls at the same time, so apologies from their end. He's failing, I think, Andy just dropped a message that he may not be able to join this call, but yeah, so which is why he's sharing.
We'll discuss on this, you know, later on this call. So, Team, thank you. Welcome to this call. Thank you for finding your time and happy Thursday. Let's get this started.
Please let me know once my screen is visible to everyone.
In a few seconds, it would be.
It is.
Thank you. So we are reviewing data for the month of April in the month of May. So which is why I'm in, because we are having this MBR in the month of May. So I'm naming as May 2026. Agenda highlights, nothing has changed, but I'll just quickly walk you through. We have highlights.
Performance KPI analysis of Alex, Sky, ITBD, CSAT, US holiday schedule.
and IT, AI by design, way forward with Deirdre technologies and recap, which I share at the end of this call via email. Now please feel free to chime in. We would love to hear from you, your insights, your feedback, suggestion, anything.
I captured these some of the highlights. So Alex exceeded his ticket resolve rate target for the month of April. And he consistently met his available target as well in this period. And of course, as he always say, he's happy to be a part of the project work he's getting.
Other breakfast tasks.
I would also like to hear from you, Wayne. Anything, any observation from your end?
No.
All is well. Yes.
Is it doing good? Okay, thank you. Good to hear from you.
So let me move on to the next one, performance analysis. Yeah, so this is what we have incorporated with, you know, showing SOP status of past five months on Jim's recommendation.
So these are from December, Jan, Feb, March till April. So in April, I see this little decline by one or two SOPs. He worked on 6 SOPs and total time was spent 1.94 hours on this.
Is it doing good as far as SOPs are concerned? I know you may not be fully satisfied because you want this number to be a little on the higher side, but I want to hear from you.
Yeah, we definitely want everyone to be doing better with SOPs, including Alex.
Sure, thank you.
So, as I shared the last time, I know we do have...
a separate ticket created for these SOPs wherein, you know, people maybe from the technical side, they put in links for those SOPs where they think some improvement is required or some new SOPs need to be created.
Ohh.
Do you think you know that ticket is being followed up or being actively managed, you know, by Alex or Amit?
Yeah.
You know, not really. I think occasionally we have people put some time in that one, but the main goal is anytime.
Uh, you know, an alert is generated, or you know, a client opens a ticket.
that we follow and update the SOPs as we're working the ticket, rather than setting aside a specific time to go look at SOPs.
Mhm, Okay.
Point taken. Thank you. That will be helpful. And I'll share this with Alex.
Do you have access? Do you have access to our SOPs? Okay.
I, I do not, no.
Thank you. Moving on to utilization trend and analysis in comparison to the month of March. His billable target in this month, which means month of April, remained 73.49%. I mean, his total number that he achieved target was 70% that was decided previously.
However, if you think he's able to achieve this target, we can alter that and we can stretch this to 75%, whatever you feel like. So currently he's targeted 70% and he achieved 73.49% and non-billable time remained 26.51%.
On an average, we see in all these weeks in the month of April, I was able to meet this target number. So in the first week, which is, I'm counting from April 6 to 10, 73%, then 77, 73, 71.
Yeah, do you think any alteration is required here?
I, yeah, I see no reason to change this.
Okay.
So, majorly, his call drivers in this month remained majorly guardian boards, which he is accountable and responsible, and should be the should be the owner for, and the other two tasks which were higher on his board were backup and 365.
Anything more you would like to add here, Win?
No.
Okay, thank you.
Ticket resolve rate in the month of April. So in the blue bar, I'm mentioning the number of tickets he walked and in the green bar, number of tickets he was able to complete resolve. I see second and 4th week showing the highest number. He walked on 139 tickets.
was able to complete 125. And in the third week, it was 99-91. But in the last week, he again touched 140 tickets, was able to complete 127. So as far as the resolve rate is concerned, from my side, I have no complaints, but
Realistically, do you have some, well, some, you know, extended expectations from him?
No, this looks great.
Okay, thank you. I've also mentioned the number of tickets, the total number of tickets he handled in this month, those were 483 tickets in the month of April, of which he was able to complete 439 in the month of March. That was about 30 tickets list.
2830. So he worked on 455 in March and was able to complete 419.
Yeah, so average ticket we see in a day, because majorly he has to review alerts and close those tickets. Those may not require major or large time entries. So he's able to complete those tickets really quick, which is why on an average daily basis, he's touching 26.7 tickets.
as of now, particularly in this month.
Any observations at your end on this piece, Wayne?
Not really, I...
Mhm.
Is there?
go along, they're probably going to be taking more of the very simple tickets, and Alex will be working more of the complex tickets.
Mmh.
That'll be great. Thank you.
Which will probably skew these numbers a little bit, but...
Are we anticipating this change in the month of May itself or maybe?
Um...
It might be noticeable in May.
Okay, sure.
And would those resources be, I know you intend to hire on-site resources because they can assist your team going on-site, client sites as well. But if you think you required someone just like Alex, so let us know, you know, for remote profile.
We can send you a resume for that as well.
Absolutely.
I know, previously we followed up with Jim. So Jim said, I mean, it is not needed as of now. So, yeah, but we'll keep checking on you because situation may change at any point of time. And then it becomes my responsibility to support your team at the same time. Just keep asking where we can help.
Thank you.
Sure.
Well, thank you, Wayne, for filling up the survey. So Alex received a positive CSAP for the month of March as well as the month of April. And yeah, so whenever he hears that he's getting good service, so he feels encouraged and appreciated. So thank you on that.
I made a little change on this slide. Yeah, just added the text column on the right side. He has already consumed his option holidays. As you know that he can choose out of these five options, he can choose two. So one, the first one he has taken already, which is Holy.
First of all, in March, and the second one he has planned in.
Ohh.
I'll double check with him because previously I think, you know, he was saying, but now immediately, maybe he has, you know, asked me to, you know, switch to Diwali, but I'll double check on this. Okay.
Camp.
That was a last minute change. And PTO confirmation. So PTO request has been sent to you, Wayne, for May 26th. And there is ITBD holiday as well. I think he wants your club to have extended weekend to spend some time with his family.
I believe he needs to, you know, visit, you know, someplace with his family. So travel will take some time. So please see if that may be feasible at your site. Otherwise, I will just communicate to him.
I need to support business.
Yeah, that's good. I thought I responded to that email.
Oh.
Or maybe that one hasn't been sent yet.
Okay, I think we have not received it yet, but I'll double check again.
Thank you on this, so IT by design services and events.
I'm sure our CX team must have shared these details or build it event. You know, this ITBD does organize this event every year. And this time again, so this is happening in the same city where ITBD head office is located, that is in Jersey City, New Jersey. And so this is from...
This is a three-day wind from 3rd to 5th in August, 9 A.m. to 5 P.m. I don't have to share much of the details, so because I'm in the interest of time, but yes, there's a QR code and ticket price is $14.95.
1495, please let us know. I mean, this is so this time, because we know that we are in the, you know, slowly and gradually, not slowly, but this time, you know, really quickly, we are.
We are heading into the AI world, AI era, and so this is impacting our day-to-day routine jobs drastically. So which is why, you know, art seminars, be it AI accelerator or build it event, most of these events are focused on.
AI. So, I mean, if Jim or you are intending to be a part of it, to have more understanding, you know, how this MSP world is changing, so I insist you to that you must attend this.
Okay.
Should I send you the link to reserve your tickets?
I know I won't be going. I almost never leave northern Minnesota.
I understand. Yeah, someone is required, you know, in the absence of Jim when he's out.
So Andy, if you see now, you can, if you see the chat, so he has shared details, link as well. And of course, oh, it's a BOGO offer, which is a buy one, get one. You can get, okay, you can get 2 tickets at 1495. Okay.
Okay, that's an advantage now.
Sure.
All right, so we'll hear from you. I'll send this over email as well, or I'll request my team to get in touch with you and Jim or any other team member you or Jim decide to be a part of this event. Please do let us know. Thank you.
Yeah, by design, so this has already been discussed. We have various services that ITBD is working on simultaneously. And I'm sure many of these will also be touched upon in this event of three days. So we'll get more insights. Yeah, I don't have to touch much on Team GPS. You know it.
There's a QR code, very easy for everyone. Just scan this QR code. And if you're looking to incorporate any sort of portal which can manage some of these features, detailed features are.
You know.
Great in number, I would say. So, currently, we are mentioning only six here, so this is what team's job is to expand the entire, you know, set of features, what this unit portal holds, so do let us know and they will explain and give you the demo.
Last but not the least, my focus is going to remain on Alex to keep improving on his SOP numbers, as you suggested today. Not specifically, you know,
finding extra time for SOPs whenever he's working on ticket. So I think, you know, if he has a SOP open at the same time, so he can just click on edit and make the required changes, take a screenshot from that portal, because I'm sure that portal is, that makes sense, because it was working on some backup ticket or maybe some Microsoft ticket. The portal is already open. He just needs to capture.
the information, click on edit, paste the screenshot, and just edit some notes then and there. A little bit done and dusted right there. Thank you.
Next one is.
We need to support Alex to be consistent with his productivity, as he has been, and identify any areas where he can add more value in your environment, and of course, organize any collaborative activities, such as...
Outdoor activities, I mean, previously I was sharing last month we needed, we had planned, we needed to go out on a trekking, but that could not be materialized because some of the team member, I mean, he fell ill. I mean, who was the main guide for this event, trekking? So he fell ill because of which, I mean,
the entire plan, you know, when and rain. And so let's see if you're able to decide in the month of June or maybe it'll be postponed to July or August, because July will have monsoon. And during that month, we'll be getting heavy rain.
you know, on every alternate day, so it will not be feasible. And there will be a lot of landslides here in India, you know, in the mountain areas.
So, some of the roads, you know, get blocked and it takes days to, you know, fix those things, so that I mean the next event doesn't happen like this. So, yeah, but my focus is to I have some plan with my team. That is it, Wayne, from my from our end. So, this is a way forward from our side. I would like to hear from you. Anything?
that you may be anticipating. We should be focusing on something else maybe that we are not showcasing or reviewing on these calls that must be added or discussed. Anything, any thought maybe coming to your mind?
I don't think so.
No.
mediator between you and that team to get this going.
No, I don't think so. Yeah, it's on me to get it going. I think I saw that that had been put on my schedule sometime in the near future. So
I'll make note to look at it again here to make sure that it is.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you. I just wanted to make sure that it shouldn't be from our side that, you know, you know, our team is lingering on the process. I really want them to, you know, get this completed if the ball is in our court. But take your time. Something needs to be accomplished at your end.
Please do take you on time, but do let us know when our information is required and we'll work on it.
Absolutely.
Thank you, Wayne. That was can be all as far as the presentation is concerned. I shared my screen. I've already asked, I mean, where we need improvement or is there anything?
Because sometimes we intend to fix something in our organization. Is there anything where I or my team can assist you with those pieces?
I can't think of anything at the moment.
Okay, feel free to let us know and it's not that
The finance, you know, will be in picture. Maybe some minor help is required, just like we did the other time. Prevent reference of alert for Jim. If there's anything I can be helpful, maybe, you know, coach Alex or assist Alex on certain things.
So, I mean, we'll be glad to help you to add value.
Great.
That is the that is the whole intent, that's it.
Thanks.
All right, so that was all from my end. Kevin, anything from your end before we wind it up?
No, I'm good. Thank you, Evan. Thank you, Evan.
All right, so thank you, Wayne. That was completely all from my end. I'll share the meeting minutes, you know, after this call. And we'll wait to hear from you and from Jim, if there's anything from your end that you would like to see going forward. I hope things are moving in the positive direction.
I do that.
Thanks, bye.
Wave one. Thank you for joining in.